So today I want to tell you about two things
that are related Bernoulli numbers
and Faulhaber's fabulousformula.
So when I was a kid I kept a journal and I
also had a math journal where I kept all my
secret private musings about math. When I got
to Princeton I asked one of my professors my
first year in college um about a question that
I was looking at in my journal and she said,
I don't know the answer to that but you should
go talk to this guy John Conway - you might
have heard of him. I actually only
barely knew who he was at the time.
- (Brady: So you weren'tlike,
oh my God John Conway!)
- I had just had a vague idea yeah yeah which
was probably good. So I went home and emailed
him and uh he said come talk to me. I brought
him my journal, he looked at some of the things
I'd written in there which was very kind of
him; and then he told me about Faulhaber's
fabulous formula and the Bernoulli numbers and
that actually uh led to what I work on in research
today in an active area of mathematical research
in number theory.
- (So you were introduced to these things
by John Conway himself? Amazing. Do you-)
(do you remember the day?)
- Uh I do and in my regular Journal I
journaled about it. It was in the spring of 1999,
I'd have to look up the precise day but it was a
beautiful spring day in 1999.
- (Where do we start?)
We're going to ask ask a few questions about
sums of numbers. So what is the value of 1
to the k plus 2 to the k plus 3 to the
k plus dot dot dot plus n the k for k,
some positive whole number. And um just to make
sure we're on the same page, so for example if n
equal 100 and k equals say 2 we're looking at 1
squared + 2 squared + 3 squared plus dot dot dot
dot dot plus 100 squared - and uh so on. So if
k is zero this is really easy, because we've got
1 to the 0 plus 2 to the 0 + 3 to the 0 plus ...
it's just 1 + 1 plus ... + 1 n times; so we getn.
If we look at first powers then we have 1 + 2
+ 3 plus ... plus n and there's a formula for
this which people sometimes learn in school. You
might know how to prove it, there's also a proof
on Numberphile in some previous episode. And so
this is often written as n times n + 1 over 2,
so we could compute this guy easily. Now
what if you want to work with squares or
cubes? So what about this number from
before, so we had these squares ...
plus n squared equals- or cubes or fourth powers
and so on; so the question becomes what are these
numbers, how can we get it? And uh you can't just-
if you try to just generalize the approach in that
other Numberphile video from this guy and you're
like, okay I understand that so got good intuition
I'll try to do that for squares - you might be
able to push things a little further but once
you get to cubes and beyond that kind of trick
is going to become ou- just a mess. So- oh do
we have more paper? So this is where Faulhaber's
fabulous formula and the Bernoulli numbers come
into play.
- (So is the fabulous formula what is
going to solve that problem for us?)
- It is yeah,
yeah it's the formula that solves it yeah. Faulhaber
said, okay I want to look at 1 to the k -1 + 2
to the k -1 + 3 to the k -1 plus ....
plus n the k-1. That's equal to 1/k times - um I'm
going to put something in quotes right now and
then I'll explain it because well there's two
reasons it's going to be in quotes. So we're going
to look at n + B to the k, so we've gone down 1
here and up here, minus B to the k. And I haven't
told you what this B is here, you know n is it's
our whole number, these B's are going to tie
into the uh Bernoulli numbers. This is going to be,
I'll have to tell you what the stuff on the right
hand side is, but this is Faulhaber's fabulous formula.
(I'm assuming Faulhaber themself isn't the person who
called it the fabulous formula?)
- Uh no and I'm not
sure how it originated; uh certainly John Conway
called it that and but- you you would want- I don't
know whether it's safe to attribute to John Conway.
He and Richard Guy in their book - do you know the
Book of Numbers? They write about this in the Book
of Numbers. Certainly sounds like a John Conwayism.
So I'm going to have to tell you about these
B to the ks; these B's are going to behave in a
way that usually would be quite quite weird. Okay
so how to define B to the k? Now first of all I'm
going to define a number B zero with the- look we
have a subscript here. This is 1 and I'm going
- that's a definition there - and I'm going to define
B subscript k equals B superscript k. This looks
terrible, looks like I took a power or something
and then I just used a superscript - I still have
to tell you about this guy though. And then for
k greater than 1 we're going to put B - 1 to
the k equal B to the k. This is a rule and we're
going to use this to define all the other B sub k's.
So eventually things are going to drop down here.
- (Are B Bernoulli numbers?)
- Uh the B sub k's- oh yes and these are
the Bernoulli numbers.
- (Okay cool, just checking)
- Yes thisis the kth Bernoulli number. Let's compute
what B1 is, since all we know so far is the value
of B0. So if we want to do that we'll use this rule,
we have B - 1^ 2 = B^2, so doing this I get B^2.
-2B + 1 equals 0; just skipping the step of
canceling the B squareds. And so this tells me then B1
equals 1/2 and remember we drop our subscript down
so this becomes the first Bernoulli number. So this is
our first Bernoulli number, the value is 1/2. You can
continue like this, you can keep computing these.
So if you- should I do another example?
- (Let'ssee the next one)
Okay so now let's find B2. So for
that we have to raise now to the third power; and
the B cubes are going to cancel again and then I
have -3B^2 + 3B1 - 1 = 0 having just canceled
the B cubes already. And I know what B1 is because
we just figured that out, that's 1/2, and so now
I have -3 and - I'll just drop my subscripts down
since I know I can do that from my rule - equals uh
1 - 3 times 1/2 since we just figured out that
this guy is 1/2. So we have over here 1 minus
3 halves minus 1/2 - great. So B2 equals 1/6.
I'm not going to keep doing examples all day!
(All right, so we get a whole bunch of Bernoulli numbers)
- Yeah we get a whole bunch of them. Yeah so now
we've computed a bunch of Bs and I assert,
following what Faulhaber told us, I assert that
we get this formula so you can expand this out and
plug in the B sub case. I just want to say a little
bit about where this comes from. So just to make
sure we see what's going on in an example we're
going to do this with a small value of k. So if I
want to know what 1 squared + 2 squared plus ...
plus say we care about- and we just want to go
up to 100 squared is; then what this formula
says is okay our k here, uh this is this is
k - 1 here on the left hand side, 1 to
the k - 1 so that tells us k must be 3. So
we have 1 over 3 here. And then we have our
n is this guy, so that's 100, plus B cubed minus B
cubed and we're just in this little example going
to expand what this looks like. (100 + B)^3
minus B^3 = 3B^2 times 100 + 3B1 times 100^2
plus 100^3 and then I have a B^3 here
that cancels this B^3 so um this is what
we get and then we say oh, I'm going to drop
these guys down, so I have 3 times B2 times 100 + 3
B1 times 100^2 + 100^3. And if you cared to compute
this you can plug these in because conveniently
uh you just have me compute B1 and B2 so we
could even plug these in here. So now we've got
3 times 1/6 times 100 + 3 times 1/2 times 100^2 + 100^3
and you can compute this big number if you want. So
now I'm going to just tell you a little bit about
where this fabulous formula comes from. So let's
look first at a slightly different expression; n
+ B to the k minus- I'm going to subtract off n +
B-1 to the k. And when I do
this, well remember we had
this rule here so we had this thing. And so when
I do this I'm going to get this pol- using the
binomial theorem I'm going to get this polynomial,
looks almost the same on each side except we have
different powers of of B and powers of B - 1
there and when I unfold this whole thing I
get j equal 0 to k, k choose j, n to the j. And
then I end up with over here B to the k - j
minus B - 1 to the k - j. And if I look
back most of these gu- most of these terms are
going to be zero because I have B - 1 to a
power equals B to a power and here I'm comparing
B - 1 to a power uh with B to a power.
Except for this rule only holds for k greater
than 1 and so what we're going to be left with
at the end when we work through this is um k times n
to the k - 1. Okay so we unfold this, we got
a bunch of zeros except preceding the term
n to the k -1 and there we preceded by 1 * k. And so
we were left with this and so now when I want to
get Faulhaber's fabulous formula I have that uh-
well first first of all we've just seen that
what this tells us is that n the k-1 equals 1/k
times (n + B) to the k minus (n + (B - 1)) to the k. But I want
a whole sum I don't just want one term here, so
what I do is now I'm going to- if I want to add
up all the terms, so if I want to look at n the k
+ 1 + n -1 to the k -1 plus ... all
the way down to 2 to the k -1 + 1 to the k -1 I'm
going to have to add up 1 over k times- now I have
n + B to the k - n + b - 1 to the k - that just
takes care of the n to the k-1 term.
Plus I have n-1 + B to the k minus - just to
deal with the next term - n -1 + B -1 to the k and
then I get to the next term which is the n minus 2
term which is going to go here: n - 2 + B to the k
minus n - 2 + B -1 to the k plus ....
until I get to the end where I look at the one
piece and that's going to give me an 1 + B to
the k - 1 + B - 1 to the k. So this first piece is
our n + B of the k that we have at the beginning
of Faulhaber's fabulous Formula; 1 plus B minus 1 this is
equal to B to the k, and everything in between
is going to cancel because they have n plus B
minus 1 or n minus 1 plus B. Addition uh commutes
so these cancel. Now I have n minus 2 and up here
I have 2 times -1 so that's going to cancel and so
on and we can keep playing this game until at the
end all we're left with is 1/k times- at the end
of the day we get our n + B to the k minus B to
the k and we get Faulhaber's fabulous formula.
So I've skipped over a few details but people
who are interested can also uh check those. And
that's Faulhaber's fabulous formula and the Bernoulli
numbers. And one thing that's really cool with
these Bernoulli numbers is they show up in lots of
places; you might have seen them defined in other
ways. They show up in Euler's formula for values of
the Riemann zeta function at positive even integers
and those numbers there are also encoding uh
really deep information from number theory which
is the field I work in. And so one of the reasons
I really like these is they're not only convenient
in solving this cute problem is that they tie to
really deep um mathematical phenomena.
- [John Conway:] It was sonice not worrying
anymore that I thought I'm not
going to worry anymore ever again. I was going to
study whatever I thought was interesting and not
worry whether this was serious enough.
Because you
know you've got one 2 at the end of it, next time
here you've got maybe it's two 2s, I don't know.
But anyway it will be 2s. So the the left hand
sequence always ends in a 2 and the right hand
sequence - well look, it goes 111312